foreign
good morning it'd be 10 o'clock criminal
justice Public Safety Committee is going
to open for business if you wouldn't
mind rising and joining us in the Pledge
of Allegiance
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands
for all
at this time I'm going to open the
public hearing on hb143
and we're going to recognize I don't
know who we're going to recognize
introduces anyone seen representative
testerman
yeah would you please introduce to Bill
okay good morning chairman Roy members
of the committee for the record I am
representative Jennifer Rhodes I
represent Cheshire District 17 which is
Winchester Richmond Swansea Troy and
Fitzwilliam
I am here this morning to introduce
House Bill 143
is that the one we're doing yep
but they say two different okay relative
to wiretapping to record conversations
related to domestic violence
I am not the sponsor nor co-sponsor on
this bill I am simply here because I see
that our colleague is not here this
morning
so I believe we will leave it up to
anybody that is here to testify to
talk about this bill
chair we'll call uh Pamela kylake
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Pamela kylig I am the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence which represents our 12
community-based crisis centers in the
state I'm here today to provide
testimony on HB 143 which would allow a
person to make a recording without the
consent of another person being recorded
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today I just wanted to speak
this morning because the Coalition while
it supports the intent of this
legislation does share some concerns
regarding potential unintended
consequences that this bill could have
in domestic violence cases we really
appreciate the sponsor's intent in
creating Avenues through which victims
can better obtain evidence against their
abusers without being prosecuted for
breaking the law
however we feel that more work needs to
be done to ensure that this law cannot
be used against victims by their abusers
as well as ensure that such amendments
wouldn't conflict with any privacy laws
in the state or any rules of evidence in
the court so
um that's those are sort of the main
concerns that we have today and why we
feel that more work is needed
additionally I just wanted to note that
the governor's Commission on domestic
violence sexual assault and stalking has
been tasked to review and analyze this
very issue and we ask the committee to
consider either retaining or killing
this bill until the commission which
includes a wide variety of stakeholders
has a chance to go through their process
and making sure that all considerations
are made when putting forward a policy
like this so with that I'm happy to take
any questions and thank you for your
time this morning
thank you I I have a question could you
give the committee an example of how it
might be used against a victim yeah
um absolutely so I think
kind of in a general sense
um there's not there's not a lot of
parameters here about the timing that a
recording is made how it's going to be
reviewed and authenticated
um so we're concerned that this would
actually allow someone to set up a
camera and create a scenario in which
you know a 30 seconds of a of a much
longer situation could be selected to be
provided as evidence to show that me
like for the abuser to indicate that
maybe the victim was actually the
primary aggressor in those cases so
that's just one example but there's a
lot here that again while we appreciate
the intent of the legislation we're
worried that it could open the door for
misuse of the statute
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you had mentioned
that
about some language that you thought
would be would be better suited for this
bill I'm not sure if you're prepared to
give us an example of that today do you
have any kind of suggestions on on that
yeah no thank you so much for your
question I'd be more than happy to
um uh look into that a little bit
further this is something that has been
on the radar and is something that we've
been talking about
um you know as a coalition and as
stakeholders but have not landed on the
right way to do it other states have
moved forward with this legislation but
I don't think we found the perfect
balance to make sure that we're honoring
um the rights of defendants in these
cases but also ensuring that victims are
protected as well
thank you Mr chairman uh my follow-up
question
um would be in the event that the
committee is to retain this bill which
is one of the suggestions that you had
I'm assuming it's safe to assume that
you would be willing to come and and
work with a committee on that yeah
absolutely and of course we'd want to
confer with some of our stakeholders on
um that just to make sure again that the
language is a really strong policy and
would be
um again aligned with all of those other
pieces like privacy laws and rules of
court
representative Muse
yes thanks for taking my question Are
there specific situations that you would
want to make sure that a bill like this
covers and other situations that you
feel should be excluded from coverage in
a bill like this
thank you so much that's a great
um I would love to Circle back on that
and get some more information I know
um they're just with the I'd want to
just check in with a few other folks
just to make sure I wouldn't propose
anything that would be wrong
there'll be no further questions thank
you very much for your testimony this
morning
thank you
um at this time the chair calls Marissa
Chase
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee I don't often
um come to this committee for the record
my name is Marissa Chase I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice which is these
euphemism for the Civil Plains of spa in
New Hampshire we have about 400 members
Statewide New Hampshire is a small state
with the collegial bar so our members
practice anywhere from personal injury
medical malpractice workers comp family
law and we do have some criminal defense
lawyers as part of our organization
however I do not Advocate on their
behalf just to clarify that our members
want to be a resource to any legal
questions you may have I myself am not a
lawyer so if you have a question for me
I can't answer I can get the answer from
someone who has it I'm here in
opposition to this bill today
um kind of going on what Pamela said
this is an issue that many of our family
law practitioners have wanted to address
and we've been kind of working on this
language or potential solutions for
frankly years along with the Coalition
and unfortunately it is the state of the
law that if a victim of domestic
violence records their own
abuse they could face prosecution and of
course I think the intent of this bill
is to make sure that doesn't happen
however I did talk to a criminal defense
attorney about this bill and as a
criminal defense attorney he said I
would love this
um which I think is not the intent and
why more work needs to be done so please
know that this is something that lawyers
are really interested in trying to come
to a solution with it's just a really
hard needle to thread um so that's why
we would ask for more time and perhaps
the completion of the governor's
commission
um to try to come up with that language
and not have some of those unintended
consequences
if you know
um the current state of the law if
notification is provided does that then
make it admissible in other words if you
come into a room and I say to you just
for the record I want you to know that
this conversation is being recorded
you have a choice to walk out or stay
I will get a more concrete answer with
citations to case law that I'm sure I
have talked about that
um my gut says that notification does
not
equal consent
okay thank you
representative sailing
sorry thank you thank you for taking my
question I couldn't hear at the
beginning what's the name of the
organization
sorry the New Hampshire Association for
justice
again euphemism for the trial lawyers
I see no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
at this time the chair calls Ross
Connolly
is there anyone else here wishing to
testify who hasn't filled out a pink
card
so you know when I hereby close the
public hearing on HP 143.
the committee will be in recess until 10
45.
I'm going to we're going to be entering
an executive session
um on the bill we just heard uh after
speaking with the ranking member I think
we're all in agreement that we are going
to
um we're going to kill the spell put it
as an expedient to legislate and let the
governor's Council on domestic violence
finish its work and come back to the
legislature when they have a uh a bill
that's been thoroughly vetted has anyone
um oh let me just open up
yeah I should probably open a hearing uh
here executive session on HP 143 is open
um can I get a motion please
Mr chairman I would make a motion that
we um in experience legislate house bill
143.
any discussion
representative Muse
yes Mr Speaker I'm sorry Mr Mr chair
[Laughter]
do you want it
um
uh a decision to itl this bill would if
if the house goes along with it would
effectively remove it from the calendar
and
as I understand it could also
potentially remove uh and the potential
for us to introduce a similar bill in
the remainder of the session
so my my question is is rather than
rather than it yelling the bill would it
make more sense
to try to retain the bill
um
perhaps see what the governor's
commission does come up with and then
perhaps we would have a starting point
um
I'm just just throwing it out there I
actually I I agree in my initial uh in
thoughts were to retain the bill however
after speaking with the domestic
violence Coalition
um they are not the opinion that they
will have something by September which
is when we'd have to file a new bill
anyway so I just as soon get it off our
plate because we'll have to deal with it
again when we come back
so they don't anticipate anything being
there representative Bolden
was the motion seconded it was by
representative
representative scitec did you wish to
speak
yeah I'm opposed to it I'm opposed I
will vote for this bill to pass I'm
willing to take the hand-fisted approach
I hear these objections as dilatory I
don't think they're uh substantive uh so
that's enough of my speech and I'm not
going to object to consent calendar
thank you
any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
the Motions inexpedient to legislate
Mr Rhodes
yes
uh Pratt Kevin
yes representative Pratt
yes
representative scitec
representative pruell
you betcha
representative janvin
hi
representative Manion
yes representative Reed
yes
representative Stone
representative tensar
yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
yes representative bouldin
yes
representative Newman Sue
yes representative Mercy Murphy
yes
representative Newman yes
uh representative Newell
yes representative selig
yes
um I vote yay
okay and uh chairman Roy
chair votes yes
what is the total
18 volunteer one vote day
18-1 the motion passes
representative scitec has indicated that
he will not object to consent does
anyone object to consent
seeing none it will go into consent
representative scitec will you wishing
to make a Minority Report
oh no no no no no not uh very good
no Minority Report
and uh congratulations to the members
you've all just had your first executive
session
get ready for many more
at this time I'd like to Grant a couple
of minutes to a distinguished guest a
former long-time member of the committee
has asked permission to give us a quick
quick address so
um I will let him take the mic
I don't know what he wants to say so
thank you very much Mr chairman uh thank
you uh for listening to my brief remarks
um I was on this committee for a total
of eight years and went back then it was
called State institutions uh as criminal
justice and Corrections I spent four
years in this room
I just would like to put out some of the
things that I found from experience
being on this committee
the first thing I found that made me
feel a little bit uneasy was that we
basically only hear from one segment of
the correction the criminal justice
community that would be uh the County
County Prosecutors Chief of Police
Association law enforcement
that kind of uh the commissioner
Corrections what have you those are the
kind of people that testify in front of
this committee and valuable wonderful
stuff
what I found is
we're missing something something is not
coming here to the hallowed Halls so I
asked the commissioner a commissioner of
Corrections at that time if he could
write a letter for me that I could go to
any Correctional Facility in the state
of New Hampshire
he did and I did I spent hours at just
every uh State institution prisons
halfway houses parole probation I rode
with all of those fellows spent the day
at a shift not in and out spend a whole
shift up at the prison
I found it very very very
informative to get the point of view of
the people who are actually out there in
the field
when you're racing around at 120 miles
an hour in the state police car chasing
some felon a propoted felon uh you start
to get a different perspective of what
this committee really does
the second year of my uh the second
session second term I should say
I spent a lot of time in the courts and
by in the courts I don't mean sitting in
in the public view I meant in back in
Chambers with the judges at the time
when I started that I was very very much
in favor of mandatory sentences we got
to tell them blah blah blah after
spending a lot of time in Chambers
talking with Superior Court judges
juvenile judges District judges I begin
to find out that the facts of the case
in every single case are different
enough that a judge is really the best
person to determine that particular case
I got a lot of experience with the
judicial
departments how it operates how they
think what they're up against and
believe me judges are up against a rock
and a hard place in a lot of cases they
really are
their hands are tied in many ways
so I found it very helpful in my
Endeavors here on the committee to
participate in that and for what it's
worth I would recommend that every
member that they can within their
abilities to ride with the police
go to the courts visit the jails visit
the prisons get a different perspective
of what the criminal justice element
of the State of New Hampshire is really
all about and on that I will thank you
very much Mr chairman I have it for your
Indulgence appreciate it thank you um we
we appreciate it we're always open to
wisdom from the past and uh you've given
me a great segue
um actually I have arranged for tours at
the prison with the commissioner I will
be sending you all permission slips
later you have everyone who goes there
has to have a background check before
they let you in so it's not mandatory
it's voluntary I encourage everyone to
go I'm thinking about sometime probably
in about two weeks I can do it during
the break if you want or if you don't
want to we can talk about it
he's got that thing actually they told
me they can do it two days
so but having said that
um I'll send it out in uh proposed dates
go ahead uh representative
sir are you still Don Gorman
he's asking no this one
a question are you still Don Gorman so
again what's your name uh oh uh don
Gorman that's why it's nice we didn't
hear that there we are
uh representative Psyduck
you're still here
and on that note I think I'm going to go
ahead and open the next public here yeah
we don't want to go through all the
people I know here thank you over there
and give you a lot of good advice too
yeah Mr representative Newman very much
Miss Cameron could we possibly name a
dean of the of the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee we very well may
I will take that under advisement
um okay this time I'm going to go ahead
and open a public hearing on hb160
and
representative Heinz
thank you Mr chair my name is Dan Hines
we're at Town of Bedford representing
Hillsborough District Two uh this is a
simple bill and the main intent of it is
to codify state law so under two
attempts Kia it's keeping state law but
basically applying state law to towns
and cities so under state law anyone can
be in public without a shirt on and it
does not constitute indecent exposure
the problem is some towns and cities
decided they don't like that and have
taken upon themselves to regulate that
in some fashion or another and so I knew
just a little bit of background New
Hampshire is not what's called a home
rule state so we're at Dillon State and
in Dillon States towns and cities they
derive all of their power from the state
legislature so there's two ways that
towns can go about enacting bills one is
if we have enabling legislation so for
example the legislature and there's a
chapter specifically for cities um towns
is a little more convoluted but
basically legislature says cities can
make regulations affecting and then list
whatever you want to affect so when
that's not there towns can't do it but
if there is the enabling legislation and
in this case I'm not sure exactly what
the enabling legislation was but rather
than taking broad Strokes to our
enabling legislation statutes I went
about this way so the other way the
state legislature can step in is what's
called preemption so for example
um if this
yes Firearms one example so for example
if the state
um
Firearms I guess is the best example
um the state says towns cannot regulate
Firearms so that's a specific one the
other one is there's I guess implicit
preemption where if the state I'm trying
to think of uh
uh let's just say there's a state law
that says you have to be
20 to chew gum the towns can't then come
in and just change that because it's
specific enough so the this bill
specifically says towns and cities
cannot have a regulation opposing or
going against this the reason this is
needed is Laconia and Guilford possibly
some other towns I don't know of do
prohibit certain people and his females
from being in public in some form or
another without a shirt on and I
litigated this in front of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court unfortunately
lost it in a 3-2 decision we tried
appealing that to U.S Supreme Court they
ultimately did not accept cert in that
case it's rare for them to actually
accept cases they accept roughly one
percent of the cases that come in front
of them and in this case they did
actually ask the Attorney General to
respond which they don't typically do so
and there's at least in my opinion some
interest from the court to hear this but
essentially towns have been applying
their laws regulating people wearing a
shirt in public in a discriminatory
fashion
um so that's what I'm attempting to
address and like I said it says legal
under state state law there hasn't been
any issues with it um so Hampton Beach
um regularly people are topless at the
beach so both gender Sexes
um there hasn't been any incited
violence there hasn't been any issues so
essentially all this bill is doing is
telling towns and cities
States in charge of this issue
you know happy take any questions do you
have or did you email the committee I
believe I I didn't I usually email
afterwards just to kind of address
everything so I will email the committee
about any testimony that I write up and
I will attach a copy of that decision
for the that's what I was interested in
the decision and if the and in the
Supreme Court if you have the uh
attorney general's opinion uh that would
be helpful
uh
uh yes uh so I can just send you extra
things if you want to look at I'm fine
uh so I have yeah our petition to your
Supreme Court have the Attorney
General's responsible why the court
shouldn't hear it
um and so yes I can submit all that
documentation for you
thank you
um questions representative scitec
uh representative Heinz you uh omitted
something in your discussion about the
interaction of the state and towns and
that's local control uh are you just uh
what about Canada town is this issue so
Monumental that we have to preempt local
control
thank you so I personally oppose local
controlling leads to locals controlling
you in a certain fashion in this case
locals are controlling people based on
their sex I think that's important I
don't think they should be able to do
that but at the end of the day the
legislature is well within our authority
to do that by by default towns don't
have local control the legislature is
actually the one who has to give it to
them
um and I looked at the enabling statutes
I don't know if they were relying on the
welfare one which is very broad or there
is basically a catch-all one they might
have been relying on that one so rather
than removing a ton of local control
um I think this is the best way to go
about it um I think it's it's this is an
issue that should be uniform throughout
the state I don't think someone is a
criminal
um in Hampton Beach or the other way
around in Laconia for conduct that is
legal in Hampton Beach it's the exact
same conduct
um I don't think it's any more offensive
in one location over another
um so in this particular instance
um I think it is very appropriate to not
let the locals decide that issue as far
as Laconia goes it's my understanding
um that Laconia did this as a result of
years ago
um so Laconia has bike week it's my
understanding that in the past men were
harassing women to
use a nicer phrase show your breasts
um and so that's how it goes about it I
don't know why they didn't punish the
people or try to deter the people who
were harassing people as opposed to
presenting people preventing people who
willingly want to just not wear a shirt
for whatever reason
percent of Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I'm just trying to
understand this so if we were going to
have house session
and every woman that's in the State
House is a representative they decided
to come in with no bra no top and just
be completely topless this law would say
that that's okay to do
how session we apply to house rules but
presently every woman in the state can
be right here in this room topless is
legal under state law uh so as regards
to the house session
um we if we're talking about the
chambers we do have specific house
decorum rules I personally don't know
that we address dressed like that um I
remember in the past we did try to
regulate it so
uh I I was just house sets their own
rules this wouldn't apply to house rules
but it is present under law for any
woman to be
not with a shirt here
representative Newell
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I just wanted to clarify
um of course businesses still have
control over what happens in their
location this would be something that's
in uh you know public property just like
the state house we have certain rules
for that any business would have their
rules for no shirt no shoes no service
kind of thing thank you uh yeah so this
would prevent towns in cities from
making it criminal and I use the word
criminal kind of broadly so if someone's
charged it does have to be a violation
level offense but they do get charged
with the violation ticket they have to
go in front of a court all the same
criminal rules of procedure applies this
eliminates that but to answer your
question uh yes this would not apply to
local businesses so local businesses
still can have no shirt no shoes no
service
I have a question
um so what about venues for example I
know at Bike Week there will be certain
venues where they'll have certain events
this would not apply if the if the
person who was running the venue said
everyone has to wear sure
right so assuming the venue was some
organization rather than a government
entity then yes they could set those
rules as I guess dress for how they want
their patrons to be so it would only
apply to
um state property or town property
it
this I will also include the copies or
the actual two ordinances in effect so
um one of the towns was more broad than
the other um we limited it to the beach
and one limited to the public I forget
which was which doesn't really matter
um so it would
I'm trying to think of an example of
where on I guess if the town did say you
can't do it on private property this
would also go against that I I think one
of the towns did have it super broad
that it would apply to my front yards I
guess
um potentially an issue there but
essentially
um yes businesses and organizations can
still regulate the manner of clothing of
people on their property
okay thank you
any other questions
representative Newman
um Laconia prohibits exposure do they if
this law were passed would it prevent
all towns and cities from making any
restrictions
um
other than the ones you said like
private property and and things like
that on public property so this the
intent of this is specifically to
prohibit Laconia Guilford in any other
town from regulate making it against the
law for someone to be topless in public
um the reason being it is legal under
state law so I'm basically applying that
state law to towns and cities telling
them you cannot contravene state law in
this issue
thank you
representative sailing
thank you um I'm just trying to
understand so
um if the two of us were in Laconia
and we both were walking topless
um is the law such that I would be cited
by the Laconia police and you would not
be or would we both be eligible to be
subjected to the same law so I'm just
trying to understand if there's Equity
under the law now or if this would be
helping to make it equitable
there's no equity under law now you
could be cited I could not
um I do believe they have a policy of
not taking people as someone complains
but putting that aside um yes their law
is sex
um based um one of the town and I will
submit the ordinances um regulates a
little differently I think one of the
towns focuses on nipples where the other
focuses on breast but for the purpose of
that yes they do distinguish upon a
female breast which led to interesting
questions of what point is uh is a girl
child allowed to do that and the police
said well we use discretion then my
other question was well if someone had a
double mastectomy twitch the response
was we use their discretion so a lot of
discretion in this but on the face of
the law they were specifically
prohibiting females from displaying
their chest
thank you for taking my follow-up so
um and currently in those towns if a
nursing mother for example or a nursing
person exposed their nipple they could
be cited because
I I'm clearly the police would have
their discretion but for exposing their
nipple to their child for the purposes
of nourishment
yeah that that's a specific issue I
don't it's my understanding they don't
affect that because I believe we have a
breast
um feeding statue and I did cite that in
my brief to the court so I I do believe
that is otherwise a dress so I don't
think it actually
it may entail that but I think that is
an exception based on another state law
that's my understanding Lee so are
various federal or other protections
any further questions
there being none thank you for your
testimony
is anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who has not submitted a card
could you please submit a pink card to
the end oh yeah I did okay
um could you come up to the mic we're
having difficulty finding your card if
you could just come identify yourself
please
representative scitec was on
um
Jeffrey yooner
unes uh yeah you you know sorry my
handwriting is uh that's not so good
when I'm nervous
uh thank you chairman to give me the
chance to speak and to the committee for
their time and consideration thanks to
the sponsors of this bill who bravely
worked across the aisle on an issue that
some people might consider insignificant
or taboo but fixes a flaw in the law
that treats many people as second-class
Citizens
my name is Jeffrey Eunice I am a
resident of Portsmouth I am a research
scientist at a small non-profit founded
the small activist group porcupine
nudists and the new body Freedom Action
Network and I am an active member in the
Free State Community
while I want to talk about the issue of
whether the state law should override
local law I first want to talk about why
this issue is important
there are many practical reasons why
people prefer to be shirtless like to
swim or when it's hot or at the beach to
paint words of support for a sports team
or to avoid getting clothes dirty while
gardening and there are more esoteric
reasons why people shed their clothes
such as to feel liberated to connect
with nature for expression to help
promote body positivity or help become
more comfortable with their bodies but
there is something more Sinister about
government clothing mandates and bans on
women being shirtless first of all they
are obviously discriminatory I can't
imagine having to be being told that I
have to wear a shirt in a hot tub with
these laws the government is insinuating
that a woman's body is harmful
especially to children it's insinuating
that the other reasons I gave for being
shirtless are unimportant relative to
considering women's bodies and how they
should be viewed primarily as dangerous
sex objects these laws infantilize women
by saying they need to be protected from
men and they can't make decisions for
their own bodies and it promotes
unhealthy attitudes towards women and
the human body
are we the Live Free or Die State or the
state that takes away women's rights
because some people are offended by the
human body
furthermore there is no evidence that
simple nudity is harmful and there's
plenty of evidence to the contrary it's
considered enriching in art and health
science textbooks but strangely the same
people are offended by the same content
and other contexts topless toplessness
is currently not illegal in most of New
Hampshire and I think that the local
ordinance in the local ordinances are
relatively recent it's legal in several
other States neighboring Vermont doesn't
even have a state law Banning nudity at
all
we've already experienced legalization
for example men had to fight for the
right to be shirtless in the 30s there
is a famous picture of a police officer
on the beach measuring the length of
women's swimsuits and more recently in
1999 breastfeeding was legalized in New
Hampshire all of these incremental
changes were initially met with moral
alarmism but I think we can all agree
that these were positive changes
nudity is not really illegal because
it's harmful but because some people
feel uncomfortable by others that act
differently what is harmful is giving in
to the least tolerant people in society
and upholding the legal doctrine that
offending others by being different is a
crime
this bill is very simple but it does two
things first it clarifies that
shirtlessness does not fall under the
state's indecent exposure law
second it prevents local governments
from passing such an ordinance
I'd like to address one valid concern of
the bill that perhaps local government
should make these decisions rather than
the state government I also prefer local
government over broader state government
however protecting individual liberties
is important to individuals and the
state alike especially in cases like
this related to discrimination
the issue of wound rights to be topless
touches on many constitutional issues
First Amendment expression and
potentially even The Establishment
Clause equal rights and equal
protections and even due process since
the state and local laws are vague and
people can be unfairly harassed by
police enforcement there are pending
cases in several States and the 10th
circuit has ruled that bans were
unconstitutional while those while the
seventh circuit has upheld the bans uh
Mr Heinz petitioned the Supreme Court
over the constitutionality of the
Laconia ordinance and New Hampshire
asked the U.S to let us decide the
matter for ourselves so we should fix it
here thank you for your time I'm happy
to try to answer any questions or
address any concerns
there being no questions uh thank you
for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who has not submitted a
card
there being none that hereby close to
public hearing
committee will
stand in recess until
12 o'clock
no 11 30 11 30 excuse me
if we get the feel for it we've got time
let me guess you're against us
I feel for Lithonia because they they
have a specific local issue or Bike Week
even if
it's okay
so do we legislate to the lowest common
denominator
yes
okay yeah
yeah that was just a faux here also just
wanted to make sure
it being 11 30 I'm going to call the
room to order and we are going to open
the public hearing on hb201fn
and I will recognize the sponsor
representative
I probably do
and it says Sykes but it's not telesky
I I forgot my glasses again so you could
be anyone I don't know please introduce
yourself
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the criminal justice committee my
name is Laura talerski I represent
nashua's Ward 8 and um I got a call late
yesterday from the prime sponsor of this
bill representative George Sykes
um asking if I could introduce it in his
place so um I hope as you can keep that
in your lens as I go through the next
two minutes
um I spent a little time brushing up on
it um because I do remember it from the
previous terms
um since 2015
driving without a license has been
classified as a Class B misdemeanor the
bill you have in front of you hb201
relative to changing the penalties for
driving without a license would revert
the statute back to how it was before
2015 making driving without a license a
simple violation
as I'm sure you are all aware of
violation is not considered criminal
however a Class B misdemeanor is
considered a criminal offense
I believe that with the attempts to
reduce criminalization in our society
for an offense as minor is driving
without a license law enforcement can
perhaps respond in a more thoughtful way
for a one-off one-time mistake like the
situation often can be
as you can see in the bill a subsequent
offense in a 12-month period time period
will trigger the misdemeanor charge so
habitual offenders will be held
accountable
a misdemeanor can follow someone
throughout their life and reverberate
through many situations
some examples could be having an impact
on future procedures one may have with
the courts it can negatively impact
someone's employment as it would show up
in a criminal background check it could
affect someone's attempt to find a place
to live a rental or getting a mortgage
it could negatively affect someone's
immigration status it could affect a
Young Person's ability to get financial
aid for college loans grants or work
study Awards and it could affect someone
interested in joining the military while
a misdemeanor can be waived it's not
automatic in a more complicated process
must be initiated
all of this because someone made an
unfortunate decision to drive without
being licensed of course we want
everyone to be licensed it's important
for Public Safety
however many times this situation
disproportionately affects our
low-income Neighbors
who maybe are challenged to pull
together the renewal fee it affects busy
working families maybe single parents
who are stretched thin between work
child care and the expiration of their
license slips their mind maybe it's a
young person who makes the unfortunate
decision to go for a joyride in their
parents car and gets pulled over and
maybe it's someone who's unable to get a
license but needs to get to work all
real possibilities but are they crimes
this bill by changing to a violation is
like a first warning and if it happens
again in 12 months forget it deals off
they get that Class B misdemeanor repeat
offenders should have to deal with the
criminal charge and the subsequent
ramifications of that
so I hope you can listen to any other
testimony today and consider passing
hb201 I believe decriminalizing driving
without a license will be an important
step towards a more Equitable and
compassionate approach for dealing with
our neighbors and thank you for taking
the time and listening to my testimony
thank you um will you take questions
sure
I have a question just for the to be
clear for the members this does not
apply to someone's license who has been
suspended for some reason it's only
people whose license has lapsed or never
got one is that correct I believe so yes
thank you
any other questions
uh representative
I have a couple questions first in your
testimony you said uh you gave examples
of how this could uh misdemeanor could
haunt this student getting a loan
getting involved you're are you aware
that in two years you can get a
misdemeanor expunged in New Hampshire
thank you for the question I am aware of
that it also is a a process a
complicated process that takes them
sorry I apologize
the second question is this uh
as you can tell I'm not a fan of this
I've read that automobiles can be
considered lethal weapons people driving
into crowds so it sounds to me like
we're tolerating somebody using a lethal
potentially legal Lethal Weapon without
training without a license
and that's what occurs to me
it is it
the question is shouldn't we be enhanced
increasing the penalty not decreasing
the penalty
in my opinion
um
I would disagree with that statement
representative Manny
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question during a testimony
you mentioned that this would apply to
people of low income people who can't
afford to get the renewal uh those that
may not have enough money for renewal
isn't this separate from that it's a
different
non-renewal or being expired is already
a violation this is talking specifically
about people who have never had a
license
is that I want to just clarify those two
I
thank you for the question
um as I mentioned I had a crash course
in the bill
um late last night as I was reviewing it
and um looking at this the part that
does make it a a Class B misdemeanors
the people who have not been licensed so
I suppose you could make the connection
that if someone for whatever reason let
their license lapse for a significant
amount of time and then needed to go
through the process to get relations but
yes
foreign
for the questions thank you for your
testimony thank you very much I
appreciate it hold on oh I'm sorry I
didn't see your representative
thank you for taking my question
um
um I was trying to digest this bill
myself and one of the one of the areas I
think of confusion for me that other
folks may also have some confusion about
is whether or not
um this would actually protect somebody
who just leaves their license at home
which I think
probably all of us have done at one
point or another
thank you thank you for the question
um I don't know the statute specifically
but I'm pretty sure that if you are
pulled over without having your license
physically in your hand you have a
window of maybe three days I know
someone from the DMV is here and might
be able to confirm that um but no it is
someone who just physically is is not a
licensed driver
representative Minden do you have some
input on that
I do driving with this this would be
somebody who never had a driver's
license and or their license expired
simply leaving your license at home I
believe it's 48 hours you have to
present that license to the officer with
no penalty that's a separate separate
statute
thank you representative
okay you're free to go thank you thank
you very much I appreciate your time
anyone else
chair calls representative Danville
hello
good morning thank you Mr chairman and
the rest of the committee uh my name is
Dan vayu I am a representative from
Hillsboro 34 representing Amherst
um
when I first found out about this bill
one of the shocking things was to find
out that it was a criminal offense to
drive first time without a license
because
you know growing up it was kind of the
a ritual of teen Rebellion to borrow
your parents car and take it for a
joyride
several friends who did that and
occasionally they would get caught and
they have to pay the pay the penalty and
it never occurred to me how serious that
penalty could be
for someone's life and someone's career
even as a young young adolescent
um
so to me it if you're shocked by how
serious a penalty is it then maybe the
crime maybe the punishment is a little
stronger than the crime would warrant
um I am close with someone who growing
up in a poor family
um her father wasn't always around her
mother didn't drive so if they needed
something at the store she would hop in
the car 14 years old and drive her
mother to the store
so to me one of the other aspects of
this is how hard it falls on the poor
who don't have access to a credit card
where they can call an Uber who might
not be able to find a ride on a short
notice who have to take chances
um
so to have some flexibility to to lower
the penalty a little bit to where it has
been historically before 2015.
would seem reasonable to me
um
so in a lot of ways this is about just
equity and fairness and making crime
making the punishment fit the crime
that's
pretty much all I have I'll take
questions if there are any
thank you I have a quick question in
your in your research
um looking at this bill
it strikes me as um on its face you may
be correct that it's seems higher than
this but is it not correct that if an
unlicensed operator gets in an accident
and someone could be seriously hurt or
crippled for Life the insurance company
isn't mandated to pay because the
operator wasn't licensed
in most cases
you're not going to be pulled over for
not having a license because there's no
way to know if if you're obviously
incompetent you know an in-app driver
there should be signs beyond your
licensure that you're unsafe and and be
able to enforce it in other ways
no I don't think you understood my
question I'll ask again if if if a say a
15 year old 16 year old doesn't have
their license yet hops in the car goes
to the store in your scenario
hits a pedestrian or gets in an accident
with another vehicle and someone in the
other vehicle at a pedestrian is
seriously injured perhaps for life
is it not true that the insurance
company does not have to pay because the
operator was not licensed and not should
not have been driving in the first place
thus leaving the other person who may
also be financially challenged or poor
unable to afford their medical bills and
things of that nature
I'm not sure how insurance would handle
that that's not my area but I know in
New Hampshire we don't require Insurance
to begin with so
it's kind of a broader discussion to be
had on that as well
so okay I was just curious to know if
you came across it while you were
preparing thank you
um no further questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
the chair calls Maggie Fogerty
okay thank you uh good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Maggie Fogerty I'm the New
Hampshire program director for the
American friend service committee and I
am not here as a lawyer or an expert on
insurance although I've been Gathering
your questions and the ones that I think
aren't answered by the end of this
hearing I I would like to gather that
information and respond to you in
writing by tomorrow morning
um
I am here as part of the New Hampshire
immigrant rights Network and we did
submit testimony to you via email I
think yesterday signed by several of our
organizational members but I just wanted
to lift that testimony up for you lift
up one or two of the key themes because
I know that you receive a great deal of
email communication so I just didn't
want it lost in the busyness of the
beginning of the year
um so we support hb201 that makes the
initial charge of driving without a
license a violation instead of a Class B
misdemeanor returning to the pre-2015
status
so something that was I believe serving
New Hampshire well prior to that time we
believe that that such a change reflects
New Hampshire a balance in the uh in New
Hampshire of wanting to uphold our
enforcement principles but also treat
New Hampshire residents fairly and not
to
unnecessarily burden them uh we think
that this bill has particular impact on
low-income residents but it drew our
attention because of what we've seen in
the past in the lives of immigrants in
New Hampshire who have filed
applications for immigration status of
some kind and are waiting not what was
normal for a long time a six-month
period until the work authorization
comes by which they can get a driver
license but now because of a tremendous
backlogger waiting more than a year and
a half so the Practical implications on
a whole family which can include uh U.S
citizen children family members is that
trying to live life in a state without a
a lot of public transportation that that
risk is more real in their lives as
people
go to get health care or take children
to school Etc so while we want people
licensed on our roads uh we're we're
trying to avoid that initial kind of
situation uh hoping that someone could
get the warning of a violation with the
threat of the consequence that comes
with being a habitual offender but in
such a way that doesn't disrupt other
aspects of their lives so I'm happy to
answer questions that I'm able to answer
or to hear more of your questions that I
could help get the information for so
thank you for your attention
representative Pratt
hello I have a question sure
sorry about that do you see a difference
between uh a person that just expired
and a person that never had a license
ever
um I don't know and I'm gonna look at
263 colon one to see what is the scope
of the current Class B misdemeanor if it
if it applies differently in those
scenarios but I don't know that there's
a difference just
just one follow-up
so a license does what a license shows
that
it shows that you've proved who you are
where you live and that you are capable
of abiding by the rules of the road
thank you yeah
representative Reed
thank you for taking my question
immigrants coming and into the United
States for the first time and want to
drive how are they getting training if
they have no license you know if they've
never taken a class you know how are
they going to know the rules of the road
and the law thank you
it goes off automatically I guess
um so plenty of immigrants come and are
able to access a driver's license
quickly others come and initiate a
process that's a long time but they
participate in the same processes that
any of us would with driver training
passing the driver's test many of them
have been drivers in their own country
so they're just learning
there be no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who has not filled out a
pink card
they're seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing
and the committee will be in recess
until when
12 o'clock sorry
foreign
each other
rights
so okay
okay
I didn't know about the smoking
yesterday wow
so
it being 12 o'clock
we're going to go ahead and open the
public hearing
on HB 292
nope that's not it what do we which one
is it
291.
and I'll recognize Senator Murphy
to introduce the bill on behalf I
believe of Representative Hayden from
time yes sir
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you
it's good to be back in front of my
colleagues in the house and I want to
say it's very nice to see my old
nameplate so uh still on use out there
although as many Murphys as there are
there's probably a huge box of them in
some basement compartment
um I have a unique
uh experience of introducing a bill I
didn't know existed until yesterday
afternoon
representative infantine
called me up and said he was out of
state and asked if I can come here and
introduce it on his behalf
and I've known representative infantine
for nearly 20 years we served two terms
on House labor together
and he filed this bill because an
experience that happened to me and he
asked me to come here and share it with
you
I opened a restaurant in Manchester in
2007.
and from 2007 until July of 2019
I had zero labor audits I had zero
issues with Liquor Commission
really was able to run my business
and generally got along very well if my
employees never had any issues
in July of 2019 I filed for divorce
and I wish I could say that was an
amicable separation but it was not
that's the way it goes
um between July 2019 and may 2022
I faced three State labor department
audits
I faced two liquor investigations I
faced two federal labor department
audits all of those cases after
dozens of hours boxes and boxes of
paperwork every copy of every canceled
payroll check every copy of check to the
Beer vendors after it was all said and
done they were all found baseless and
dismissed
it took a lot of my time as the owner it
took a lot of time when the state and
federal employees that had to spend time
in my conference rooms looking through
those paperwork and when I finally asked
my ex-wife I said did you do this
and she said
I might know who did it
um
and it was very clear that she was the
one that was responsible for those since
the divorce was finalized it's all gone
away
it's all stopped
so
um I'm here to tell you that story and
Mr infantine representative infantine
filed this bill because of that
experience and I related to him as a
friend and and he filed the bill because
of that so
if anybody has any questions I'm happy
to answer them
um
you know I generally think it's improper
to follow legislation based on your own
experience that's why I wouldn't file
the bill myself but he did it without
telling me so
thank you uh
as you're not the sponsor but perhaps
you can answer this question he went
right to felony and skipped over
misdemeanors do you have any
um specific reason why we want to go
right to felony when he brought to my
attention yesterday he said that he felt
this was the lowest level
um
the copy in front of me sir says uh C
penalty Frost complaint liquor
commission's a Class A misdemeanor
um
now we're looking the same
the same bill no you're you're correct
I'm reading again I actually I I spoke
to
um the sponsor and he had mentioned
felony so I didn't even go back and look
Class A misdemeanor
so it's it's uh eventually a fine in
practice yeah everyone hears on criminal
justice I'm sure you know that better
than I yeah okay thank you Senator
um I I'm going to um I'll probably gonna
um recess the hearing at the end of the
today and leave it open for the sponsor
to uh come in because he did want to
address us when he gets back so um
we'll keep it open for another day any
more questions for the senator
representative Newell
I guess my concern would be how would
you demonstrate that they knowingly did
this with that intent I think it heavily
relies on what their intent was and so
if you have any thoughts on how that
would be demonstrated
thank you for the question
um these departments keep a record of
who files the complaints I don't believe
necessarily in the first complaint that
would be actionable but if somebody
calls the Department of Labor for
example two or three times
and make statements to that effect I
think at some point it's pretty
self-evident
represent Bolden
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um at the time that the incident
occurred did you
were you unable to pursue charges to any
other Avenue
thank you for the question
um
Auditors especially from the Department
of Labor always claim that it's a random
it's a random
um audit
they never come in and say it's because
we got a complaint from this person it's
when they even say it's because of a
complaint it's kept Anonymous to protect
the the person who called it in
um so
based on the very small information I
had on any individual occurrence
there was really no one to go after
um
I did not suspect who it would be until
it got into the fourth or fifth
complaint and that point the evidence
was it just it was very clear especially
after the confrontation as far as why it
was happening and who did it
follow-up
thank you I think I only have one
follow-up question so if the identity is
withheld it sounds like the commission
would need to enforce this really to
that they would that the com
allegation of a false complaint would
probably need to begin with them
um I'm assuming because there would be
no outside entity I'm going to ask a
question this is just uh not well worded
um
so is there currently tier knowledge no
Avenue for the commission to deal with
false complaints
um since it would be their
responsibility under this proposed RSA
thank you for the question the best of
my knowledge there's currently no Avenue
for any um all they can do essentially
at some point if they receive numerous
complaints and this is according to the
last auditor I spoke to from the
Department of Labor I was very
frustrated as you can imagine and he
said look at some point if we get a lot
of complaints and it's clearly all
baseless we begin to take them not
seriously and essentially
round file them but there's no Avenue as
far as any sort of penalty resulting
from filing false complaints within east
of these departments
now representative Bolden it's my
understanding that this could actually
be enforced by any law enforcement
agency in the state it doesn't specify
who has to enforce it so someone could
just go to the police and then the the
commission would have to provide the
records as part of Discovery I believe
any further questions
representative Muse
and again understanding that you're not
the the sponsor of the bill one of the
things I I um
that is a little concerning to me is in
the the third section where the bill
says
um false complaint to the department any
person who knowingly makes a false
statement or complaint to the department
for the purpose of harassing or damaging
the reputation of a business owner
she'll be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor
um I guess this is
special protection that we would be
granting to one particular group of
people in New Hampshire
and I think it's something that we
occasionally
do but probably don't like to make a
habit of doing uh
and one of the things that I'm trying I
would like to understand is
if you can if you can better help us
unders
understand and maybe better quantify
the damages that were actually done to
you by this conduct it would be helpful
to have a little bit more understanding
of the
I understand the question and I
appreciate it sir the um
in this case and I completely agree that
it's improper generally to pick out
certain segments of our of our citizens
and provide them with special protection
in this case the departments in question
are only going to be going after
business owners they're not going to go
after just anybody that doesn't own a
business who can't
it doesn't harm
um to use my example it doesn't harm us
one of my servers necessarily their
their reputation to file a complaint
with the labor department it just only
harms me as the operator
so that's why it specifies that but as
far as quantifying it each one of those
labor department and liquor department
audits
15 to 20 hours
to put together the paperwork
and box it up provide it for the uh for
the the inspectors
um
and in in my business as in any other
business time is money that was time I
couldn't spend rewriting menus hiring
employees doing inventories Etc
did you um did you hire counsel during
any of these
I uh had my attorney who was
representing my interest in the action I
spoke of and it was addressed in court
I'm asking because what a business owner
if you know typically have to hire an
attorney to weed through this process or
an accountant or is there any ancillary
expenses possibly attached to one of
these audits
uh I did have to hire my accountant and
have and specify that they needed to put
together the accounting paper business
owners tend to run several months behind
in accounting and just the nature of
what we do
um and I had to pay that person to bring
it up to speed as of that moment and uh
for the inspector because inspectors
when they come in they say we want it as
soon as possible we'll be here next
Tuesday please have it ready
um it isn't as if we have weeks and
weeks to prepare
um I would also just want to point out
that it isn't so much my time that was
the major concern for me it was annoying
don't get me wrong it was frustrating
but a lot of my frustration came from
the fact that this state has limited
number of employees and there are real
problems need to be addressed and those
state employees were instead their time
was being wasted on my case
all of it was baseless and all that was
dismissed there was nothing to find
representative Newell and
thank you chairman
um my question uh you know I've seen
this in my own life and um you know
people who I know
um that you know there have been false
complaints um
unsubstantiated complaints later proven
unsubstantiated to on about individuals
to another department which is to say
the Department of Children and Family
Services
I don't know if you have children
um I unfortunately have been through
that and it's it's been a tough
situation I'm curious
um you know in writing this bill and I
know you didn't write it yourself
um why something like that wasn't
included as this just focused on
business and the the financial impact or
I also faced three different dcif
investigations all of which were
ultimately dismissed as baseless so
there's this is one segment of a very
broad frankly campaign against me
personally as a parent and as a as a
as an individual in our state
my understanding is that there's another
bill that was followed by a different
representative addressing the dcyf issue
so I'm happy to say that that get
addressed but evidently it was an
infantine felt that this was appropriate
for
these departments
and you will have a chance to ask the
sponsor because I am going to keep this
in recess so
um representative salute
thank you for taking my question um I
just want to clarify so this would be
specific to complaints made to the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission
um I I just want to because I know like
many businesses and restaurants after
I've been to them have made requests for
me to post reviews and so if I were to
say post a really negative review of a
restaurant because
either I had a personal Grudge or I had
a bad experience
um I just want to make sure I understand
that this is specifically if I'm making
a false allegation to the
representative the stat the bill clearly
says um
to the department to the department to
the Department
I believe
oh yeah it will
yeah Liquor Commission
that's that's correct it wouldn't
reviews would not have any impact
foreign
thank you
is there anyone else present who wishes
to testify who hasn't filled out a pink
card
okay there being none as I said earlier
I am not going to close this hearing I'm
going to recess it the prime sponsor
wishes to address us so I may schedule
it to open and then we'll probably exec
it thereafter so it doesn't eat up more
time than it needs to so at this time
I'm going to recess this hearing and our
business for the day is concluded
um just for everyone's information
um check the State website if if they're
gonna close for tomorrow if the speaker
decides to uh close it'll be posted on
the House website I intend if he doesn't
make me um to continue with our business
for tomorrow we have a lot of bills I
can't afford to take a snow day so if
I'm in here by myself you can watch me
from your house having hearings if you
don't
foreign